yah vamp oj Psicosis terrorism liaison
group the person or Chicana
voix boy freaky puñado de volta a
fedora Freddie beta component is I say
taro puja initiative ces armatures
que nous faisons ici est complètement
sans précédent Marvel prend tous
les personnages qu'ils mettent  dans
leurs films et les réunissant tous
dans une expérience de film de franchise d'équipe
qui n'a jamais été faite
avant
Ageha Kumasi dans un sort vertigineux ou
quelque chose que
deux sois parlent d'une machine plus complexe
ici essayant d'
interfacer ces personnages là où ils ont
tous un sens  tous ont des arcs et personne
n'a à faire trop de travail lourd même si
tout le monde passe sa journée au soleil Judi
ton épique omnia brume aux joues roses wa
machine tu me dois appliquer des croyances pas de
chance
je vais prendre tous ces personnages et
tu essaies  pour faire d'une
réalité une situation incroyable, elle a arrêté de
planifier, nous avons les héros les plus puissants de la Terre
et ce sont tous ces
acteurs extraordinaires qui jouent le  voir
des personnages extraordinaires quand avez-vous
déjà vu ce groupe d'acteurs
se réunir pour la première fois que vous voyez
tout le monde ensemble BAM
il y a les Avengers Avengers devrait
être notre meilleure heure
Meza me yo laisse notre une fœtotomie zéro
[Musique]
toi